generation Zed can expect to have as
many as 17 different jobs over five
careers enrols that may not even exist
yet they're going to need to embrace
lifelong learning so how do we raise
kids with a desire to learn and grow and
how can we teach better and as we get
older and busier how do we keep our own
love of learning
alive well with me today is the man who
makes maths fun teacher extraordinary
already
with me today is the man who makes maths
fun teacher extraordinaire Eddie woo
he's known as students around the world
as Mr wube and he's also a professor of
practice at the University of Sydney's
School of Education where he teaches the
next generation of teachers Eddie it's
great to see you mark likewise Eddie how
do we instill a love of learning in kids
love of learning which is so important
and so underrated when we think about a
syllabus document which is what is it
teaches bread and butter recognizes we
want students to learn about this we
want students to learn how to do this
but that love of learning if it's not
there to begin with and sustained and
fostered it doesn't matter what all the
rest of those content dot points or
skills may be and when I think about my
own love of learning and where that's
come from and where I see that little
flickering flame that I might meet in a
student I think there are lots of
different aspects for how to develop Ma
I mean the first thing obviously in some
ways is for the teacher themselves and
that's the lens that I bring to this to
want to be so engaged with that learning
themselves that they are modeling for a
student what it looks like to be a
Learner in that space I guess what I'm
trying to say is that the teacher in any
context and this is if you're someone
like me at the front of a classroom or
if you're a parent with a child or even
any person who you get to interact with
and help them learn you're the lead
Learner in that relationship and that
relationship word is key it's not just
about conveying information even if that
is in a clear and and exciting and
engaging way it's also about navigating
the dynamic between you and the person
you're helping to learn and to be able
to say okay not only can I model for you
what it's like to be interested and
engaged with this to help you be
interested and engaged
but it's also about saying I care about
you as a person I care about you enough
to know what makes you tick and to know
what your very unique brain needs to
connect you into I'm picturing sort of
two cogs uh coming together and in
needing to get their teeth into each
other for the human being who's the
learner to engage truly with the ideas
or the skills I want to learn with I
need to know a lot about that person so
I get yes there's two things there for
you to begin being able to model that
excitement engagement myself and also to
have such a deep knowledge of the
learner themselves that I can know which
part of this idea whether it's calculus
and trigonometry or things outside the
realm of mathematics that aren't my area
of expertise to be able to help them
connect to the young person i' I've
heard it said that there are some
teachers who love their love the
teaching there are some teachers who
love the
subject are you saying that a a teacher
to be a great teacher needs to love
learning themselves absolutely and in
fact I think it's a false dichotomy I
guess to list them out in the way and I
know that's not what you meant to sort
of portray but actually I think that
that's a a common dichotomy that people
think about and because you know as
human
beings there's lots of research into how
bad we are at multitasking what we truly
do is we single task and our Focus and
our attention goes from one place to
another and we switch back and forth
quickly enough sometimes to give the
illusion of thinking about more than one
thing at a time but I truly think that
in terms of those things you just
mentioned the content the teaching but
also the joy of learning itself all
three of them need to be bound together
in the teacher and in the dynamic with
the student so how do you engage kids in
learning I love to begin with stories
and I think that's because
well not only do I personally enjoy a
good story I think we're all wired for
that I mean thinking back to if we
rewind just 300 years just to be
conservative which is really just a
blink in the eye of civilization in a
pre-literate society how did we learn
how do we learn and the answer is we
learn by telling stories and even though
a subject like mind mathematics doesn't
feel like it's a very storytelling
narrative heavy subject compared to say
the humanities uh that's a misconception
every great idea when we're learning it
uh it can be thought of in the framos
say for example the most basic of
narrative storytelling tools three acts
setup conflict resolution I've got to
know I've got to be oriented I've got to
care about this there has to be some
Clash some way that this idea maybe
seems paradoxical or counterintuitive
that I I want to resolve in my mind and
then there has to be a synthesis of who
I was before with new knowledge that
I've come to encounter that's what the
resolution is and you can teach anything
in that way so there are tools of the
trade that certainly once you learn them
they make teaching and engaging a
learner a lot easier and is there also a
mindset that you know if you can teach
anything that someone can learn anything
what you know you're you're a mass
teacher there are you know plenty of
people who've told themselves all their
lives that they're not a math person
they don't get math are there people who
are maass mass people and not maass
people I would have to say that
autobiographically I think that I am the
living contradiction to the idea that
there is such a thing as a mat's person
and then there's the rest of us me
Mortals because growing up I never
really fully grasped what maths was
about I could go through the procedures
which is what a lot of people I think
would remember back in their school days
they might have learned a formula or a
procedure here's the steps that you do
out pops the long division answer don't
ask me why any of these steps mean what
they mean but I can do them and I can do
them correctly that was who I was when I
was at school and so to have come from
there to now where people are shocked
when I meet them and I say I I've
struggled with mats all my life in fact
I kind of still do I think that's one of
the secrets to how I can teach
effectively because I still have empathy
with the people I'm trying to help learn
I guess that's my way of saying if
there's such a thing as a maths person I
guess I wasn't but now I am which kind
of proves that change is possible one of
the things we know is you know the
nature of work is going to be changing
technology is going to change the shape
of jobs you know you sp still spend a
lot of time in high schools how how do
you help young people today plan for a
career that can take so many different
forms and is still it could well be
totally unknown one of my favorite
things about teaching and learning
mathematics which doesn't seem like it
has to do with this question but I
promise it does is about the fact that
it really is about helping anyone learn
how to think in a logical and deductive
way and that doesn't just have to be
with numbers and shapes and patterns it
is much broader than what most people
would think of as mathematics but one of
my favorite parts of what we call
mathematics is problem solving and the
best definition I think there is for
what problem solving means is it's what
you do when you don't know what to do
and there is a set of systematic
approaches that anyone can take when
they're trying to make sense of a
situation that is novel and confusing to
them to start to unpack maybe if we
break down the situation into its
component parts maybe if we were to try
and draw it out systematically or
perhaps if we could think of a simpler
version of this and come up with a
principle that helps us understand that
situation then we can broaden it these
are the kinds of things which I think
are fantastic tools for equipping
students to walk into a world that they
can't predict and I can't predict but
when they get to a place where they
don't know what to do they will still
have something to do so now you're not
just teaching high school students
you're teaching at the University and I
know you've been teaching long
established Math teachers or Primary
School teachers as well um do adults
learn differently to children
adults do learn differently to children
but I would say not as differently as
some might think I'll give you a couple
of examples in both directions so number
one do they learn differently yeah they
do uh in terms of an adult brings with
them uh some advantages and some
disadvantages that are very different to
what a child might have so in terms of
that breadth of knowledge an experience
and the importance of being able to
connect uh purpose to a sense of uh
moral drive that's something which is
characteristic of adults any adult
learner who I've worked with has a
pretty good sense of why they do what
they do and why it matters and if I
can't connect what I'm doing uh and what
I'm helping this person to learn then
that's going to fall flat really fast
whereas with a student we have I'm not
going to say tabula Clean Slate there's
no such thing as that but you do have
something which is much more unformed
and still taking shape to be honest with
you that's one of the best things about
working with adolescence they're still
working out who they are and what
matters to them what their values and
priorities are so in that case it's a
much sort of broader sense of here's
something which may be of interest to
you you haven't necessarily made up your
mind about that but suspend judgment for
a moment and come on this journey with
me down the rabbit hole and let's see
how this can connect so that's an
example of a difference in the positive
direction I would say one of the
disadvantages for adults which we just
have to reckon with is neuroplasticity
is definitely a thing we used to think
that the human brain was locked into
place after sort of you know depending
on who you ask age 18 or perhaps age 25
after the prefrontal cortex forms but we
have learned so much in cognitive
science over the last 15 20 30 years but
just how plastic and changeable the
brain is uh all all the way into there's
no limit to it 50 60 70 years old there
are still things where areas where the
old dog certainly can learn new tricks
so that's speaking to the
distinctions but I think one of the you
know misconceptions is that it is
totally different to teach an adult
versus a child for example I know this
is going to be potentially a
controversial thing to say but my
experience with teaching tens of
thousands of people has given me lots of
grounding and confidence to say this the
idea that we're very young children we
should you know talk to them for short
amounts of time and then give them some
Hands-On activities have them working
together but then once they're adult
let's Z them down and let's talk at them
for an hour continuously and not have
them move let's put them in a dim room
and have PowerPoint slides up on the
screen which have upwards of 100 150
words and let's also at the same time
say things audibly that are completely
different to what they see on the slide
adults will be fine no no they will not
they will struggle with the same Clash
of overloading cognitive uh load and uh
the visual spatial sketch pad in their
minds clashing with their auditory
processing these are things that are
common between young and old so yeah
there are differences but maybe fewer
than think but is it ever too late I
mean if you if you think of someone
working now in the sense of the world so
dramatically changing around say with
the arrival of these new powerful AI
tools that are going to change the
nature of work and change workplaces if
we want to learn something new I think
it's easy to get feeling like well this
is just so overwhelming so so how do we
get the confidence that the train hasn't
left the station that I can still get
across and master this totally new area
h
there's a few things I would say to that
maybe two to begin with the first one is
that the pace of change is incredibly
rapid it's true and it's there's no
sense in trying to dismiss that uh and
to you know sh it under the carpet but
at the same time the pace of change that
we're seeing say for example I am of
that generation who grew up truly
without the internet or social media and
I now live in a world in which we are
saturated dare I say
oversaturated with data that we're
swimming in some of which we create some
of which is just coming at us 24 hours
that's a different world from what I
grew up in but at the same time it's one
I've learned to navigate and one that
people much older than me have learned
to navigate and successfully in fact I
would say more than navigate have have
mastered and the knowledge that those of
us who are older bring to this rapid
pace of change is a steadfastness and a
groundedness in knowing that there are
some things which are coming up which
are novel and which we need to to grab a
hold of uh and and learn a lot about but
there are also things which don't change
uh say for example we were talking about
teaching and learning before and in a
classroom context
technology and the way that it's used in
classrooms is very different but it
hasn't changed the importance of
relationship and being able to have that
Rapport and dynamic with students it's
just a new context in which for that
Rapport and dynamic to develop so I
think I guess I'm trying to say is you
asked about giving hope before in a time
of Rapid change being able to be well
grounded and anchored in those Timeless
truth becomes more important than ever
so that's just the first thing I would
say and second in closing
knowledge is not individual
I think that is an idea that we have
perhaps
accidentally inhaled and integrated into
ourselves particularly Western post
Enlightenment it's a very
individualistic way of thinking about
things and to be fair a lot of the way
that we think ourselves in terms of
learning say for example our leaving
certificates at the end of school or
university credential they belong to to
you and you alone but real learning is
corporate it's something which you and I
for example Mark we know things together
and I would never dream of saying that I
know all the things that you do but I
know that I can access them and in some
way actually they are I can say that
they're mine I share them with you and
so I guess what I'm trying to say is for
those of us as we grow older and we see
this pace of change and it's it's
concerning perhaps even disheartening I
would say
this is time to lean in with those who
are perhaps younger than us but not
necessarily younger than us those who
just know more in a particular field and
to say well let's let's learn this
together and let's
co-design our understanding of this it's
something that I know I've learned a lot
from my My First Nation colleagues they
would think about this idea of
individual knowledge is quite strange
and that's one of the things which I
know I've I've benefited from